they said yesterday
75 of the people dying have four
comorbidities meaning they're pretty
sick people and that many of them are
dying with covid as an incidental
finding all right he came in he lost his
arm his leg and
his ear was cut off from an automobile
accident and he also tested positive
from covid but he died from internal
bleeding but he also had coveted but see
when they're waking up to it and when
you have cnn doctors saying
cloth masks are nothing more than facial
decoration guess what maybe yeah they
are i think understanding that there are
more deaths under biden than there were
under trump that they got some
explaining to do and their best way is
to explain this as something we're gonna
have to live with
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the junior senator from kentucky the man
that anthony fauci has endless
nightmares about and now i think it's
fair to say a reuben report regular
senator rand paul welcome back to the
reuben report
well thanks for having me uh you had
quite a day today another uh fight or
what do we want to call it fight what do
you want to call it i don't want to
qualify but you got into it without you
again what do you make of this guy
yeah
and you keep coming back to personal
attacks on me that have absolutely no
relevance to reality do you think
anybody has had more influence let me
finish this than you have do you man
yes do you think it's a great success
what's happened so far do you think a
lot of people said good for our kids do
you think we slowed down the death rate
more people have died now under
president biden than did under president
trump you are the one responsible you
are the architect you are the lead
architect for the response from the
government and now 800 000 people have
died right so you think it's a winning
success what you've advocated for
government
senator first of all
if you look at everything that i said
you accuse me of in a monolithic way
telling people
what they need to do everything that
i've said
has been in support of the cdc
guidelines
wear a mask
get boosted and you've added it back to
make it course take a look at everything
advocated to be done by mandate but
you've advocated that your infallible
opinion be dictated by law i've always
been pro-vaccine i'm just simply against
authoritarianism and against mandates
the anger that's developed with you dr
fauci is that you don't want to give us
advice you want to tell us what to do
you think you are the science and that
anybody responds to you how dare you
how dare you criticize science as if you
somehow are science
that kind of arrogance that hubris is
really
that's where the anger is coming towards
you
if you were one doctor a man hundreds of
doctors in the government who gave
advice
i don't think anybody people might
object your advice but there wouldn't be
such a degree of anger but you are so
certain that you're right that you're
not willing to hear anyone else
three epidemiologists of which you are
not even an epidemiologist but three
epidemiologists prominent in their field
oxford stanford and harvard you maligned
them you spoke openly with dr collins
and you did not disagree that let's
paint them as fringe
you went after them and said we will do
a public take down
not in science or nature or lancet in
wired in the nation a left-wing
publication you've engaged in base
politics you wonder why there's so much
anger you're not an objective scientist
you you've lost that long ago
and so many of the things that people
want it's like they want to know why
you're forcing their children to be
vaccinated when 95 percent of people at
risk have been vaccinated over 95 of
people over 65 it's a huge voluntary
success and yet you won't rest until you
force every child to get this so yes
there's a great deal of dissatisfaction
with you and many people want you to go
but nobody wishes you violence
uh no i think he deserves everything he
gets and then some to tell you the truth
i mean we probably never had a
government bureaucrat have this much
power over our lives and this much
disdain for our individual liberty
and really when you've got a government
bureaucrat a government doctor who
believes and will tell you that i am the
science and any criticism of him is
basically seen as criticizing science
can you imagine the arrogance today went
one step further and he says
if you have the temerity to uh question
him over him going after these
epidemiologists that wrote the greater
barrington declaration if you have the
temerity to do that you're now guilty of
fomenting violence against him and it's
it's a terrible sort of accusation to
make and i reminded him that look i was
there on the ball field when a bernie
sanders supporter almost killed steve
scalise
a staff member was shot less than 10
people 10 feet from me but none of us
blamed bernie sanders for that none of
us really said oh you can blame a
left-wing politician for some crazy
supporter of theirs and yet that's what
he did today and the left-wing media
lapped it up
so knowing that the left-wing media
which is basically all the mainstream
media isn't going to frame any of this
in an honest way it does seem that the
narrative is collapsing for the people
that are paying attention that a lot of
the stuff that you've been talking about
for quite some time is starting to
bubble up you know they're sort of
admitting you get the vaccine it doesn't
quite work the way it was promised the
mass don't work well like promise the
blocks down lockdowns don't work like
promise are you feeling that there is an
actual momentum shift and what do you
think that'll look like at a national
level if so
you you may have seen this in the last
year or two that some people suspected
that the death count was inflated that
many people were dying with kovid and
not from kovid
wow the biden administration has woken
up to this fact and we're getting
regular pronouncements from them day to
day they said yesterday
75 of the people dying have four
comorbidities meaning they're pretty
sick people and that many of them are
dying with covid as an incidental
finding all right he came in he lost his
arm his leg and uh his ear was cut off
from an automobile accident and he also
tested positive from kovid but he died
from internal bleeding but he also had
coveted but see when they're waking up
to it and when you have cnn doctors
saying
cloth baths are nothing more than facial
decoration guess what maybe yeah they
are i think understanding that there are
more deaths under biden than there were
under trump that they got some
explaining to do and their best way is
to explain this as something we're going
to have to live with how how much of the
negligence do you think at this point
trickles up to biden and i'm saying that
specifically that way that it trickles
up to him because i don't think he
really has a good handle on what's going
on here but you know we've all seen the
videos a month or two ago if you get the
jab you know you're gonna you're not
gonna spread covet et cetera et cetera
you won't catch covet that's obviously
not the truth i mean what has to happen
to some of these people right from biden
to fouchy to wallensky at the cdc etc
if it's trickling up to him it would
have to be mashed and made for
edentulous food that you feed to the
elderly i mean i don't think he's in
charge of a whole lot of things i would
say that
um he's indirectly responsible for it
because he did say over and over again
he was going to not lock the economy
down he was going to lock the virus down
and now more people have died under his
watch he did blame president trump he
says he's responsible for these 200 000
people dying it was a ridiculous
statement and no honest politician
should have been allowed to get away
with it and the media should have gone
at him and said that's not fair and yet
the media bought into it and it was the
narrative that the virus was trump's
fault but now the virus goes on and
seems to be really
uncontrollable um in the death's mount
now it's sort of well you need to accept
it really the cloth masks don't work
they're trying to find a way to get back
to normal because guess what the blame
is attaching to them but almost all of
the things that you see are from
government planning government policy
and socialism they're in charge of the
testing
they're the ones that are mandating how
we do the test so everybody's got to get
a test so if your five-year-old's got
covid and you really wouldn't know it
but you test them and they've got
coveted now you got to test the whole
class then you got to test all their
siblings then you got to test all their
parents so this thing sort of spreads
out its tentacles spread through society
and the government will say oh we're not
for lockdowns but we are for testing
everybody if you test everybody
inevitably it leads to a lockdown
so this is a real problem most of the
people on the hearing today with voucher
like oh why can't the government make
more tests i'm like why the hell are we
ordering so many tests this is about
ordering too many tests and it's about
testing people who are not sick people
who are not sick should not quarantine
and people are not sick shouldn't be
taking tests or medicines we should
leave them the hell alone but that's our
real problem and who gave us all this
advice falchi
you know so biden's taking falchi's
advice but fauci is the problem so i
mean i think i know your answer to this
but should fouchy just step down i mean
it doesn't seem to me that this is a guy
who should be running the nih anymore i
mean it's enough's enough already
i mean if we don't have room for him in
prison i mean stepping down would
probably be okay but no he's a menace in
the sense that uh
he really is careless and callous
towards our liberty he uh his first
impulse is always an authoritarian one
but he also ignores the science so by
conservative estimates over 100 million
americans have gotten this 62 million on
the official website have gotten coveted
but the nih has studies that say five
people for every person diagnoses at
least five people undiagnosed
let's say it's only one or two we still
get to well over a hundred million maybe
half of america has been infected if you
don't count them then you think we're
woefully short on vaccines then you
mandate it on children but the other
thing there you know you would never
know this by watching cnn or any of
these other
networks that are full of fake news
if you look at how many people have been
infected naturally and you say well how
many people have gotten the vaccine
95 percent of people over 65 have been
vaccinated it's even higher if you go
above 75.
the the voluntary vaccine has been an
enormous success but if you watch cnn
you think oh gosh nobody's been
vaccinated the truth is the opposite
almost everybody that's at risk for this
disease has been vaccinated the children
are getting it naturally whether you
vaccinate them or not now adults are
getting it whether you vaccinate them or
not really we're headed towards where
there's going to be enough immunity
within the community and i think the the
devolving nature of this is towards a
cold we have four other coronaviruses
that cause the cold this is going to
become the fifth coronavirus the sooner
the better and then we also at the same
time we'll have some people dying the
vulnerable people let's try to save them
by getting government obstacles out of
the way so we can have more monoclonals
again and more of the new pills
but also let's repurpose some of the
things that we have out there that
lessen inflammation
i want to shift a little bit to the to
the big tech thing and i know you're on
a time crunch but just one or two more
things on this uh first off you know
obviously you've been talking about
libertarianism and individual rights and
the constitution all of that old school
stuff for for years and years and years
and your dad before you um are you
sort of
shocked how this covid thing has
unmasked so many of your colleagues
people that you maybe had political
disagreements with but that just went so
all in on just government government
government
i guess i'm not very excited about
having some
snot-nosed punk over at facebook or over
at twitter or over at youtube uh decide
they're going to judge the science um
you know it took a little bit of effort
to get to medical school it took a
little bit of effort to get to one of
the better medical schools in the
country and i got some kid who's lucky
if he has a journalism major who's lucky
if he ever took a science class doesn't
know what organic chemistry is telling
me that i'm promulgating misinformation
so it's really insulting but also on
another level on a very personal level
these people despise us we are the
deplorables to them we are the people
who live and fly over country and we are
the people
they would look down their nose at us
with contempt so why do we give them our
content everybody this is what makes me
mad about conservatives libertarians
they're all complaining saying oh i hate
the big tech and we should break them up
no that's a big government solution quit
using them if we all quit using them we
are 40
strong at least we're maybe closer to 50
of the country we quit using twitter we
can topple them instantaneously just my
shift to you to rumble i think is having
an effect but i'm one of maybe 10 or 20
prominent conservatives and libertarians
up here what if we all did it you know i
think we really could have an effect and
the thing is is i don't want people to
make money off my content who look at me
with contempt and say oh we don't like
this we don't like that you can't
publish this oh you said this on the
senate floor sorry we're not going to
let you say that on youtube so yeah i
don't want to be associated with
close-minded people
so to that point you officially have
announced that you're moving all of your
content to rumble but it wasn't just
that you did something kind of snarky
you basically said i'll only use youtube
to attack the policies of youtube which
i saw i thought was a pretty beautiful
thing i should just say for full
transparency's sake that everyone knows
that locals my company merged with
rumble so i have some interest in rumble
obviously um
do you think is there anything the
government should be doing related to
any of this this is where the
libertarian conservative divide always
goes we've discussed it once or twice
before but is there any room for the
government at any level break up
anything
i'll listen but i'm always sort of
hesitant to believe the solution is the
government i'm also a big believer in
unintended consequences the more you
look carefully at a subject when the
government gets involved the unintended
happens one of the arguments big tech
says for not taking away liability is
that if you take away liability
protection that big tech enjoys what
they'll do is become more sensorious
they will censor more people because
they don't want to be sued and there is
some argument for saying you know dave
rubin called rand paul this on facebook
let's sue facebook well that's
ridiculous i mean we're calling each
other names either quit using them don't
listen to them turn them off or call the
other guy worst name but
if we get involved with lawsuits and
people say well what about the
old-fashioned the established media and
here's my answer give them liability
protection too instead of taking away
and this is sort of an outlier position
but instead of taking away liability
protection give it to the newspapers and
the um and to the you know to the
broadcast media as well and i would go
one step further i would also
let newspapers and
television organize the bad word for
this is collude but i would let them
organize to try to set the prices for
their content for youtube and facebook
the big complaint from old media is they
take our content we hire reporters and
writers and we put all this money and
effort into create writing up the news
and then it's stolen from us and used on
by the big tech people don't pay us for
our content we'll let all the newspapers
in the country get together and
negotiate as a one entity with facebook
so there are ways around some of this
that are creative thinking to try to
equalize the playing field but i've
never been for oh so and so has less
regulations than this company uh you
want to equalize them let's lower the
regulations just don't increase the
regulations you know what i mean let's
try to lower the burden to equalize uh
opportunity and access to markets so
last thought just tying the covid thing
on the big tech thing together i mean do
you really sense that the future of
america is just going to be sort of
parallel societies red states will
operate one way and say people like us
will operate on alternate platforms that
will not be
the mainstream platforms that everything
is sort of spread you know splitting and
i would argue maybe that was the genius
of federalism in the first place and
it's all okay yeah
well particularly when you when you
federalize government you have the
different levels you can kind of move
where you like and uh you know if you're
into the san francisco lifestyle you can
live out there and it's whatever goes
goes if you want to live in the bible
belt it's less accepting and in a small
community in oklahoma for that lifestyle
you live there and i think some of that
is good because then we can have sort of
freedom of choice of lifestyle and
everything else and we already have it a
little bit with like marijuana and
things like that it's in the more
accepting states it's allowed the other
states it's not yet allowed and so
people can kind of gravitate and the
smaller the denomination of government
the more freedom you can have because
you know if it's a whole state it's it's
expensive to leave the state but if it's
just your town you know remember when we
had dry towns it was actually dangerous
not that i ever did this but you had to
drive to the other town and then back
you know because of course some people
would open their bottle on the way back
of course you know and that was a
problem but not that you ever you know
you've had communities and i know you
never did that either but you had
communities that sort of made these
decisions and people could choose to
live in the community they wanted to and
probably the smaller the denomination or
the smaller the size of the government
the better
senator i know you have to continue your
day of smacking around fouchy either in
the media or in person i appreciate your
time and i hope to see you soon
thank you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell